[Music]
Hello friends, welcome from St. Louis,
Missouri. Here we are at the general
conference session and we have a special
program for you here. This is I like to
know from a different place as you can
tell and we're enjoying our time here at
the general conference session. It's
been such a blessing to be able to
connect with people from around the
world. And here to my left is Pastor
Stephen Boore, the president and speaker
of Secrets and Seal Ministry. Pastor Bo,
welcome to this program.
>> It's always good to work with you,
Daniel.
>> Thank you. And you perhaps are very
familiar with our program. I'd like to
know some of you may have been even
sending some of these questions. And
today we are going to answer these
questions live for you here from St.
Louis. We have amazing questions that we
will be discussing today. But before we
do that, I would like to ask Pastor
Board to please open up our program with
a word of prayer.
>> Let's pray.
Father in heaven, we come before you at
the beginning of this day of the general
conference session that you will be with
us on this very special program. I'd
like to know. We have some very
interesting and captivating questions.
We ask for your wisdom to answer them
correctly in harmony with your word. We
ask that you will bless those who will
watch this program that it might be a
blessing to them.
>> Amen.
>> We thank you for hearing our prayer. We
ask it in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Okay, we're going to begin
with our first question here. Uh this
question comes from a brother. We don't
know his name but the last name is
Gonzalez. And here is the question. The
question is, is Moses really slow in
speech as he himself claimed? In Acts
7:22, it clearly says that he was
learned in all the wisdom of the
Egyptians and was mighty in words and in
deeds. Did he just doubt his abilities
or he thinks he lacks knowledge about
Hebrew language life? Some movies even
show that he stutters.
And what does Acts 7:25 mean when it
says, "For he supposed his brethren
would have understood how that God by
his hand would deliver them, but they
understood not." Does it mean that Moses
already know that God will use him to
deliver Israel? And lastly, Acts 7:es 30
through38 refer to the angel of the
Lord, the angel which appeared to him in
the bush and the angel which spake to
him in Mount Si. Do they all refer to
Michael and Jesus? So, we have three
questions here about Moses. The first
one is Moses's speech, whether he lacks
some linguistic abilities to speak
Hebrew. Number two was about if he knew
that he was the chosen deliverer. And
number three, about the angel of the
Lord. What can we say about these
questions, Pastor Bor?
>> Okay, regarding the first question,
which has to do with Moses saying that
he was slow of speech, we have to take
several things into account.
>> Correct. Number one, he spent his first
12 years with his mother, which means
that he would have uh spoken Hebrew. Uh
then the next 28 years he spent in the
courts of Egypt, so he would have spoken
Egyptian.
>> And then for 40 years he went and
attended Jezel Sheep and that was in
Arabia. So he must have uh spoken
Arabic.
So uh three languages are actually
involved in the case of Moses and um you
know we don't know how much of the
Hebrew he retained we don't know how
much uh of uh you know the
so much trouble he had uh managing the
languages but there's another couple of
factors and the first factor is that
Moses was very humble.
>> Yes. after spending 40 years in the
wilderness with Jethro's sheep. The
Bible tells us that he was the meakest
man on earth.
>> Yes.
>> Which perhaps he felt like he was not
worthy
>> to go and speak and deliver Israel. Uh
that's one thing which we need to take
into account. Another thing that we need
to take into account is that perhaps
Moses was actually giving an excuse that
he couldn't speak. That's usually the
argument that is used. So, we need to
take all of those factors into account.
>> That is correct. And Ellen White agrees
with the with the aspect of Moses being
the meakest man of the earth. In the
book of patriarchs and prophets chapter
22 that deals with Moses, she says that
when God came to him with this command
to go and deliver Israel, it found
himself distrustful which perhaps uh he
found himself or he saw himself as
unable to deliver Israel. Now whether he
had forgotten Hebrew or not uh that is
possible but we know that the Holy
Spirit
sharpened his linguistic abilities again
because later we see even in the Hebrew
language that he wrote his books uh such
a beautiful actually u uh linguist
linguistics and way of writing um his
books the books that he wrote. So uh
what we can say about this question then
is that perhaps even though it started
humble he ended up giving some excuses
to go and fulfill God's mission.
>> Now I could speak of my own personal
experience
um when my parents uh when I was uh four
years old my parents ac accepted a call
to go to Colombia and Venezuela. So from
the time that I was four to 14, I spoke
in Spanish
>> outside the home. In the home, I spoke
in English. However, when I was 14 and
went to Wisconsin Academy, I did not
know how to read or write English. I
spoke English at home, but I did not
know how to read or write English. So, I
got mostly Fs the first semester that I
went to Wisconsin Academy. Wow. So, uh,
I have some sisters that also were in
Venezuela and Colombia at the same time,
and they don't manage Spanish nearly as
well as I do,
>> uh, because it's been a long time since
they used it. So, it is plausible that,
uh, that Moses had, uh, you know, he
maybe he stuttered or maybe he really
did not, uh, uh, have a handle on the
Hebrew language that he had used during
the first 12 years of his life.
>> That is correct. Very good. Now, how
about the second question in Acts 7:25?
Uh, the question had to do whether God
or whether Moses already knew that God
will use him to deliver Israel or did he
found out that later?
>> Well, very clearly, Exodus chapter 3
tells us that when when God encountered
Moses at the burning bush, he said that
he had chosen him to go and deliver uh
Israel from Egypt.
>> Yes. So, I'm not sure that when he uh
after he killed the Egyptian and went to
tend Jethro sheep that at that point he
knew what God's plan was for him to
deliver Israel. Perhaps
it is possible even though we don't know
clearly but the parents of Moses when he
was born they saw in him a special child
that perhaps he could be the deliverer
and and the fact that the the mo the
mother of Moses exercised the faith to
hide him and to protect him from Pharaoh
also shows that she trusted that he
could be the deliverer. So I don't know
to what extent he heard that from his
parents but definitely his calling was
confirmed at the burning bush.
>> Yeah. And you know it's interesting uh
if you compare the training of Jesus you
know the first 12 years of his life
undoubtedly Mary saw something special
in him.
>> Yes.
>> And uh and she expected that he was
going to be the Messiah. Of course he
turned out to be not the kind of Messiah
that she was expecting. Yeah. But but
even when he went to the temple of
Jerusalem when he was 12 years old,
>> Ellen White says that he was studying a
great problem. Yes.
>> As he observed the ceremonies of the
temple. So so even at that point he did
not fully understand the plan that God
had for him uh uh to to actually fulfill
all the rights and ceremonies of the
sanctuary. Yes.
>> So I think maybe with Moses uh his
mother said you're special. You know God
is going to use you in a special way.
But uh only when you get towards uh the
story in Exodus chapter 3 does Moses
say, "Wow, God has chosen me to deliver
uh Israel from Egypt."
>> That's right. Very good. Now, the last
question uh I will read it again. Acts
7:es 30-38
refer to the angel of the Lord, the
angel which appeared to him in the bush
and the angel which spake to him on
Mount Si. Now, do they refer to Michael
and Jesus? is so Acts 7 refers to the
angel of the Lord but in the account of
Exodus it says the Lord appear to him is
also are they the same and who is this
angel of the Lord in a special way?
>> Well the fact is that Exodus chapter 3
does not only say that the angel spoke
to him. Exodus 3 says that God spoke to
him from the bush.
>> It says that the Lord spoke to him from
the bush. And so the Lord was God and
the God was the angel.
>> Yes.
>> Uh you know the thing that really
settles this and tells us that that uh
angel was the angel of the covenant
Jesus Christ or Michael
>> uh the prince of the host in Daniel um
uh the prince of the Lord's host and so
on. Uh the text that really settles this
issue of who it was is in John chapter 8
58 and 59.
uh where uh Jesus says uh most assuredly
I say to you before Abraham was I am.
>> That's the name that the person in the
burning bush used to to speak to Moses.
Yes.
>> Say I am has sent me.
>> And so uh very clearly the Jews in
Christ's day understood that he was
claiming to be the angel that was in the
bush.
>> Yes. because they trick pick up stones
with the intention of stoning Christ for
claiming to be God.
>> Yes. Very good. Thank you. Okay. Uh
let's go to the next question. This
question actually uh was sent by someone
from here from the city of St. Louis,
Missouri. And the question uh has to do
with the role and mission of the angels
as messengers from God. There are
actually several questions here. We'll
try to answer all of them together. Uh
we have a lot to say about this. So how
much here's the question. How much does
the Bible reveal about the angels and
their mission as messengers from God?
Their abilities and limitations. Angels
communication with intercession for an
intervention into human affairs. Angels
are not omnipresent. Neither good uh
good ones or bad ones. But all of our
lives, thoughts, and actions are being
recorded for judgment. Where in the
Bible does it say that we have guardian
angels? If Satan and demons cannot read
our thoughts, can all good angels read
thoughts, prayers to God or only the one
assigned to us? The statement made in
Daniel in Daniel 10 by the angels said
that it was known from the time he
started praying three weeks prior. By
whom was it known? God, of course. But
who else? Angels and demons have
supernatural and superhuman powers. Good
angels follow the dictates of God doing
his will. How regimented is Satan's army
in their intervention in human lives? Do
individual demons act on their own
recognizance or um or is there any
strict hierarchy? So these are lots of
questions that we have here. We will try
to do the best we can to answer some of
these questions. So the first thing um
I'm going to try to group them together
in fewer questions so that it can be
easier for us to answer uh these
questions. So the first one has to do
with the intercession of angels in human
affairs.
Whether there are two aspects to this
question omniresent or whether they have
the ability to read our prayers and our
thoughts.
>> Well, first of all,
uh the angels are not omnicient are not
omnipresent.
>> The angels are not present everywhere at
the same time.
>> Yeah.
>> And now I'm going to say something
that'll be very surprising.
>> Mhm.
>> And that is that God
is not present everywhere at the same
time. You say, "Wow, that's heresy."
Pastor Boore
>> Ellen White says that the father is
sitting on his throne in heaven
and he's surrounded by millions and
millions of angels all ready to perform
his will.
>> Yes.
>> When we pray, we say our father which
are in heaven.
>> God is omnipresent because he is
omnisient.
God doesn't have to be present in China.
He doesn't have to be present in St.
Louis
>> present physically
>> and in California physically present
>> in order to know everything that's
happening there.
>> So God is omniresent through his
omniscience.
>> Mhm.
>> Because God knows everything from
eternity past to eternity future. He
knows every detail. And so he's
omnipresent because he knows everything.
Uh you know and people say, "Well, what
about Psalm 139?"
Well, people think that this psalm is
about God's omni omniscience,
omnipresence, but it really is about his
omniscience, his complete knowledge.
>> It says, uh, Lord, you have searched me
and known me.
>> You know my sitting down and my rising
up. You understand my thought a far off.
You comprehend my path and my lying
down. You are acquainted with all my
ways. You know, basically that has to do
with his knowledge.
>> So the emphasis is on knowing on omni
omnisient and not omnipresence.
>> That's correct. But he is he is
omnipresent
because of his omniscience. Yes.
>> So I'm not saying God isn't, you know,
he isn't present everywhere. He's
present everywhere because he has
knowledge of everything that's happening
everywhere.
>> So that's still a divine attribute. The
angels do not have that. Mhm.
>> That's the reason why the angels
surround God's throne and God commands
them to do missions. Says to, for
example, to the angel that inspired
Ellen White, you know, go down and uh
give Ellen White this information. So
God is surrounded by myriads of angels
all waiting to perform his will
according to the spirit of prophecy.
>> Amen. Very good. So how about their
ability to read thoughts to take our
prayers and actually they have a role
that is was mentioned here in the
question even their role in the judgment
because if in the judgment even our
motives and our thoughts are going to be
taken into account and the angels are
the ones that record all that then they
must have the ability to read our
thoughts and our prayers. But how do
they do that?
Because God gives them delegated
omniscience.
Take for example in the Bible, you have
the story of Ananas and Safh.
>> Yes. Acts chapter 5.
>> And uh and Peter says, "You haven't lied
to to human beings. You've lied to God."
>> Yes.
>> How did Peter know that uh that they had
lied to God? Because because the Holy
Spirit gave him that information.
>> The same is true of Ellen White. Mhm.
>> You know, God g would give Ellen White
information about something that was
happening in some other place.
>> Yeah.
>> And people were surprised when she
revealed it if she'd never been there.
>> Because God gives the capacity to know
things that are not known commonly.
>> Yes.
>> In other words, it's it's delegate the
delegated uh capacity to uh to have
information that is not readily
available to everyone else. For example,
in Daniel 2, in Daniel chapter 2, the
king forgot uh the dream and uh and God
gave the information undoubtedly to an
angel and the angel then came and
enlightened uh Daniel.
>> Yes.
>> Uh because Daniel couldn't read the
king's thoughts.
>> He enlightened Daniel and then Daniel uh
told the dream to the king and the
interpretation of the dream.
>> Yes. So in other words, it it is not
difficult to understand this issue
because even if prophets that were there
are humans, they have sometimes the
ability to know what others are
thinking, what is happening inside their
hearts because God has given them that
ability. Then the angels, the holy
angels have that ability. Now um our
friend here was asking us about the bad
angels. Do they have the same ability?
uh Satan himself for example to read our
mind to read our thoughts you know I
heard sometime uh once when I was little
that I was I was supposed to pray only
silently in my mind because Satan
couldn't read my mind because if I if I
prayed out loud then he was going to
read my prayers and I was always afraid
of praying out loud because I didn't
want Satan to hear my prayers. So this
is it's good that we can we can talk a
little bit about this. Ellen White has a
couple of statements where she says that
when we're having struggles, we should
not express them audibly.
>> Because Satan is not able to read our
thoughts.
>> That's right. Yeah.
>> But he but he is a careful observer. He
reads our body language
>> and he hears our words. He says, "Oh, u
this individual is struggling with this
particular uh sin in in their lives, so
I'm going to focus on that." Uh, so the
fact that that the devil cannot read
people's minds is revealed once again in
Daniel chapter 2.
>> Yes.
>> I'm sure the devil was very anxious to
tell the wise men the dream.
>> That's right.
>> Uh because that would have uh given the
impression that they really uh were able
to to uh read the thoughts of the gods,
>> but they were not able.
>> Which shows that Satan is not able to
read the thoughts. Um, so, so Ellen
White does say that we're supposed to
the deepest struggle of our hearts,
we're supposed to keep in us. We're
supposed to pray, uh, not audibly, uh,
because Satan can hear us and, uh, he
can mold his temptations according to
what we say.
>> Very good. So, um, so good angels, just
to just to summarize what we just said,
good angels are able to do this because
God has enabled them, has given them the
the the ability to do it. Actually I was
trying to find a quote in ministry of
healing where Ellen White says that God
through the spirit and the spirit
through the angels has contact with all
his created realm in the universe. So,
so the Holy Spirit, Jesus through the
Holy Spirit, um, who is actually the one
leading the angels, um, and we know that
is the Holy Spirit that reads our
thoughts. But that this connection with
the Holy Spirit and the angels is
amazing and will help us, uh, understand
this more.
>> You know, we really need more time to
answer this particular question. But let
let me give you uh, I've studied this
for a very very long time.
in in the Bible, things that are
attributed to God are actually performed
by the angels.
>> Uh I'll give you se several examples
here. Um
the Bible says that the Lord God took
the chariot wheels off of Pharaoh's
chariots.
Ellen White says that the angels grabbed
the wheels and took them off. Uh the
walls of Jericho says the Lord God
knocked down the walls of Jericho. Ellen
White says that the angels took hold of
the massive walls and brought them down.
Um where I started this study on the
importance of the angels, I've always
believed that we need a 29th fundamental
belief. That is the role of angels in
the plan of salvation. Um the where I
started this study was when God said to
Cain, if you do well, will you not be
accepted? If you don't do well, sin lies
at the gate. in Genesis says the Lord
God said to Cain,
but Ellen White says that God, and it's
in the Sabbath school lesson, by the
way, uh the Lord God condescended to
send an angel to speak those words to
Cain.
>> And so, and so what the Bible attributes
to God is performed by the angel. And
then some people say, "Well, then it's
not God." Of course, it's God
>> because God tells the angel what to say.
>> Yes. And the angel goes down and the
angel exa says exactly what God
commanded the angel to say.
>> Yes. Very good. Okay. Our time is
running out. Uh but we want to finish
all these questions. I think this one we
can answer real quick. Uh is it still
related to the angels in Daniel chapter
10 where it says uh here is Gabriel
talking with Daniel and it says that
even prior to his prayer it was already
known. So by whom is this question? It
was known by Satan or was it known by
the angels?
>> Well, undoubtedly it was not by Satan by
what we've studied.
>> Yes.
>> It was actually known by God.
>> Exactly. And it goes back to the same
idea that um the angels of God even know
when we are praying. Um so lastly here
about the power of the angels uh if they
have superhuman
powers and how they follow the dictates
of God and how is this compared to the
power that the wicked angels have as
well.
>> The bottom line is that the angels have
delegated omnipotence.
They are not by nature omnipotent. Mhm.
>> They receive the ability to do things by
the power of God.
>> I'll give you an example the story of
the centurion
>> who had a servant who was ill.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh he says please Jesus heal my
servant. And Jesus says okay I'll come
to your house and I'll heal him. And the
centurion who was a pagan by the way he
says you don't have to come to my house.
All you have to do is speak the word and
my servant will be healed.
And he understood better how that was
going to happen than the Jews
themselves.
>> Yes.
>> Because basically he says uh and I had
it here but but uh time is just about
ending. Uh he said I'm a man of
authority and and I tell this soldier do
this or do that and they do exactly what
I tell them. And so basically he's
saying that as I command soldiers to to
do certain things the Lord God can
command his angels to do things. And
Elen has a statement in Desire of Ages
where she says very clearly that when
Jesus spoke the word of healing, an
angel went and healed the servant. It
wasn't by the power of the angel. It was
the power of God through the ministry of
the angel.
>> Amen. Isn't that amazing to have the
angels by our side? Um Hebrews chapter 1
says that the angels are ministering
spirits. Um actually the word angels,
angelos means messenger. They're
messengers. A messenger is someone that
is sent. Sent by whom? Sent by God for
our salvation. So, I can't wait to meet
my guardian angel. The Bible does talk
about the guardian angels. Um Jesus
spoke about do not offend the little
children because
>> they're angels.
>> Their angels uh who are in heaven uh
will not hold you uh will hold you
accountable. Uh paraphrasing what the
text says. But anyways, the time is up.
Thank you so much for being here present
and online and God bless you. We'll see
you next time.
[Music]